so once you start skating um I started
skating probably like like on the board
uh probably like 10 12 years ago I lived
in Tucson actually when I picked up my
first skateboard uh like the group of
homies I hung out with out there we were
always doing something like different
like whether it was like skating or you
know everybody was like on the club
basketball a club football team and the
homies just started randomly skating and
like I remember I pulled up on them one
day and I saw the board and I was like
oh like you know I mean I've always been
intrigued with like adrenaline rush you
know I mean I always been an adrenaline
junkie and so I used to just grabbed the
board like while they were hooping and
just roll around on the basketball court
and then I just like got hooked on it
every time I linked I couldn't put it
down I never had my own I was always
using the homies boards and then when I
moved from Tucson to Phoenix I kind of
like saw more skating went to my first
like actually this was probably like
man I want to say
2010 oh [ __ ] okay yeah probably around
there like I'll when I moved to Phoenix
from Tucson yeah uh I moved I removed
when I came I was in uh Chandler but I
lived in Glendale before I like moved
but when I moved back I was in like
Chandler area of course on that side
though closer to Chandler High nice and
then I moved like on the other side when
I started going to Hamilton so uh yeah
because most people like I mean that's a
pretty short skating Journey for you to
be like as [ __ ] popping as you are
yeah most people like man I've been
skating since I was eight years old a
lot of my homies actually are like I'm
with they all started like when they're
super younger I always tell people when
they ask me how long I'm like I feel
like I kind of started like later than
most people yeah and I don't know like
it kind of just
like zoomed like you know I moved here
in 2015 right after I graduated high
school and I was already skating and
started competing and stuff but I would
say like after that two years of living
here of just like you know grinding
filming and linking up with homies like
they kind of just like grinding and
literally grinding yeah for real and
then they're just like I don't know now
I'm here I always trip out